whether you love it hate it or never  thought about it chances are some nanny  wants to ban it presenting the nanny of  the month runners-up Evanston Illinois  where low sagging pants might get you a  fine as high as 750 bucks the comic  world's original crime fighter carted  off to Jay holy handcuffs Batman Los  Angeles is cracking down on superheroes  who take pictures with tourists on  Hollywood Boulevard we live in America  don't we but there's only one nanny of  the month and this time it's James  Kirkpatrick Commissioner of Minnesota's  Department of Human Rights oh yes not in  Minnesota where Kirkpatrick says no more  special deals on drinks and cover  charges for the ladies ladies night is  illegal look at the discriminate against  men five bars have already been charged  with discrimination Batman's in jail so  only kool and the gang can save you now  Minnesota check back next month for more  examples of busybodies minding your own  business  Oh